يكافحون لابقاء هذه الالات تعمل هنا في
احدى مطابع انقره التي تعمل منذ ثلاثه
عقود يدور الحديث عن مصاعب عديده قد تؤدي
لاغلاقها كما حصل مع مطابع اخرى
مؤسسه الاحصاء الرسميه تؤكد ان الزياده
السنويه في اسعار الورق بلغت
256 في المئه
يرتفع سعر صرف الدولار وفواتير الطاقه
والاجارات ما ادى لاغلاق عدد من المطعم
اثرت الانعكاسات على اسعار الكتب يراها
هؤلاء القراء الشباب ان شراء كتب باهظه
رفاهيه لا يقدر عليها مواطن يواجه مشكلات
معيشيه كثيره افضل
في معرض الكتاب الاخير في انقره لاحظت دور
النشر تراجعا في اعداد المقبلين على شراء
الكتب تقول بيانات وزاره السياحه ان عدد
الكتب المنشوره هذا العام انخفضه مقارنه
بالفتره ذاتها من العام الماضي
لا تتناسب نهائيا مع التكاليف التي
تتكبدها دور النشر
ادت الى اعتماد البلاد على الاستيراد
فافتحت الحكومه قبل فتره مصنعا بهدف حل
للمشكله
المصاحب الاقتصاديه تترك اثارها على دور
النشر والطباعه ويلبس تبعاتها سوق الكتاب
وقراء فيصبحوا انقاذ الكتاب امرا يستدعي
حلولا ناجعه للحديد من تداعيات هذه الازمه
فرح الزمن شوقي الجزيره عن قرا